I studied graphic design at Oregon State
and then at Stanford got a master's
degree it's in at Stanford and did my
first film at Stanford and God bless the
professor who suggested I try a film and
my first job out of school was working
on Sesame Street spots at korte films in
Mill Valley California in the Bay Area
and so we made a animated feature there
out of cut out paper and it's not very
many people know about it called twice
upon a time and so I really loved
working in the animation world but at
that point it there weren't a lot of
opportunities even Disney was hardly
releasing any features at that point and
it was really very different scene than
it is right now so after that I worked
there for six years i worked in
live-action at Lucasfilm working on
their Ewok television films and other
live action projects there and I got a
job following that up at Industrial
Light & Magic and worked as a visual
effects art director there for seven
years and that eventually led into
production design again at on James and
the Giant Peach and after that i started
at pixar on monsters incorporated
ratatouille and now i'm working on cars
too well for computer animation I think
people have the idea and it's a
misconception that the computer does it
all and that we're just sort of pushing
buttons and you know it's hard for the
the audience to really know how it's all
done but the fact that we have to design
everything that you see on the screen
and that nothing comes for free is some
is a challenge we're always up against
and that it's why the film's take four
or five years to actually make and the
the upside of that is that we can
control exactly what the image looks
like on the screen that there are no
sort of accidents everything is on
purpose and
that kind of control with the the
abilities of the the technology right
now and the tools are getting better and
better so that the artists can use the
tools and the tech folk are becoming
more artistically educated and the whole
thing I think is is coming together in a
sort of high point right now i think
it's it's kind of a golden age for
animation right now I I think well the
tools are changing very quickly and
things that weren't weren't possible on
the last film are actually I shouldn't
say easily doable but are the scope of
the film's I think our is going to
continue to grow so that the the big
problems in the past of doing cloth or
doing humans or doing effects like
flames and water those are all getting
under control so that I really there's
nothing stopping us right now I it you
know there were the early films toy
story and a bug's life and even the
first cars were designed around the idea
that well these sort of hard shell
characters are easier for the computer
to do than human characters which have a
tradition of looking kind of disturbing
at least up until recently and so now
you know I think some of those
boundaries are being broken and you know
it's really exciting for me the it's on
almost any kind of story I think can be
told right now in animation
you